j'habite paris
j'ai besoin d'un copain de temps en
temps à paris j'ai même le chien et chat
avec moi divertissement oui j'en ai eu
le choix de la compagnie
j'ai acheté que cette feuille verte est
rouge et depuis 10 ans 11 ans maintenant
un berger allemand et un chat qui
s'appelle qui sait pas le minot ils
vivent ensemble depuis qu'ils ont nés
neuf fois j'ai eu le chat d'abord en
longtemps et puis le chien werther est
arrivé je vais rapporter de l'allemagne
sur les genoux comme accrochages étaient
plus vite et plus petit que chat est
arrivé puis je grandis en fit comme une
asperge mais ils sont toujours très bien
très bien entendu le chagrin espèce de
priorité le cheval est une histoire un
peu compliquée parce que modèle chez
base
ils sont utiles ils adorent acheter un
âne pour lolita compagnie et puis le
chat est mort alors là les a pris un
coup de mieux rester ni en racheter un
cheval pour rôtir compagne alan et puis
la démo de vieillesse tout ça alors il a
fallu racheter un âne pour t'accompagner
au cheval supplique en génération on en
aime enfants sa fille s'appelle long
succession chaque fois
un mât
à
d'ailleurs je vais vous prouver au coach
paul wesley du médecin du cheval blanc
nous voulons tous je suis croque un beau
diable une cigarette
les choses telles choses nous parle je
trouve cet animal est plus beau plus
superbe
j'en fais pas moi même j à j'ai un
cheval qui courent soit les courses du
king et qui vient de temps en temps ça
souvent le temps d'autant jalousie
morbide
d'une part je monte à cheval est
perceptible ce n'est pas tant que je
pratique enfin et puis il ya un espèce
de mythe
les chevaux en dehors de leur beauté
je suis
j'ai eu de chien avant celui ci qu'on me
donne les yeux de chat j'avais pris
l'aspect a un qui s'appelle yuki
qu'était chaix qui était fugueur et bien
qui s'appelait le chien et qui finit par
inviter la campagne complètement il
supportait pas la ville mais autrement
j'ai eu des chiens et des chats ou
iguanes et pas du tout depuis que ces
petits tubes comme assez des chiens et
des chats partout pas une image
immédiate un petit poêle à soi-même à
part conditions les malades ou en visant
un malheureux qui sont des crises de vue
l'ancolie qui à ce qui leur arrive
normalement quand on parle un ballon
tombe dit eh bien mon petit peu court au
petit monde pour vieux c'est plus par la
soi même un peu un peu direct tu crois
les nantais l'égoïsme souvent chez des
propriétaires
il va leur donner un rôle dans une
fonction quand j'écris un livre une
pièce le chien prend l'année retentit
fait le chat redonna machine à écrire ce
qu'ils ont ils ont fait une corrélation
entre le mas imaginé écrit j'ai leur
pâté aux animaux assez c'est assez
comique à une fois à cheval pas celui ci
n'est un autre qui nous est moins
encline à faire du cinéma c'est au
moment où les fonds étaient un peu en
baisse ici à cause du casino dans une
quelconque et après que dans le film est
venu ici pour acheter les droits d'un
livre à moi qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait qui s'appelait marie nuages
commencent à parler de l'attribution à
chaud et doux et puis le chemin est
entré c'est un cheval qui met beaucoup
on va jouer aux cartes
quand on joue aux cartes il derrière il
souffre les variétés ils tenteraient
soit pointe des pieds si je peux dire
j'avais les doigts de quatre partait il
est similaire au lecteur il a fait comme
ça pour la soufflette son épaule type a
fait un bond de 2 à 3 heures il a eu
très peur s'est retourné qu'est ce que
c'est beau vêtement jeudi c'est un
cheval se peuvent pas poser malgré
furieux
et il avait le coeur qui bat et
toulouges et il est parti et j'allais
enfin quoi ça n'a jamais tourné dans une
major vous pouvez régler nourrir vous
même si jamais nous reviennent pousse à
venir ici
la chaux
toutes les images je crois j'aimerais
être un pari sur l'animal contre vos
voisines s'accroissant les arbres nos
soleil dans tout aujourd'hui
m
e